on today's show if i'm doing my job
right you should all
be asleep at the end because the geek
minute is back and we are talking about
all things sleep nerdy and everything
we're also going to talk to an awesome
guy whose nephew's getting out of jail
and he wants to know how he can support
him we're going to talk to the mom of
two young kids who got a dui
and thinks she's a failure stay tuned
[Applause]
what is up this is the dr john deloney
show
i'm john just like my mama named me and
i hope you are doing good
hope you're being kind to one another
hope you've met your neighbors y'all are
playing tennis i don't know i'm gonna
play tennis that sounded weird
hope you're just out in the yard kicking
a soccer ball around or doing whatever
it is people do these days with their
neighbors
and i hope that y'all are being
wonderful
with one another so on today's show
we've got a lot going on
um if you're new to us welcome
normally i am way more uh on top of
things when i start the show and by way
more on top of it
i'm not but we talk about mental health
talk about relationships we talk about
all this stuff
on this show we got a packed show today
so i want to go ahead and get to the
calls
if you've got challenges in your life
relationship issues
um mental health challenges you just
want to know how you can support folks
questions about parenting marriages
education whatever it is give me a shout
at 1-844-693-32
that's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com show
and we will get you on the show and we
will uh talk to you we're getting
calls emails from all over earth right
so
uh it's it's a it's an exciting time to
be in the
podcasting but is it it's not there's
about 11 million podcasts this is but
one
we are almost cracked the top million
though james with your great
production help we are almost cracking
the top 1 million you're welcome
that's the kind of coaching i get guys i
get the uh
you're welcome all right so let's go
straight to the call uh to the phones
today we got a lot going on let's go to
colin in fairbanks alaska
colin what's going on oh man just a lot
of good stuff how are you my friend
same same same um how's the world
treating you
dude it has been a crazy year uh
lots going on but for the most part man
it has been
incredible very cool very cool so
brother what's going on how can i help
well i've got a situation i've got a i
own a small
uh service based carpet cleaning
business
i'm an owner operator started about
three and a half years ago
very cool man um that's a whole other
story i got fired from a job and
i was tired of getting fired so i
started my own business and it's been
amazing so
hey so would you fire yourself are you
have you turned into a pretty good
employee
you know for the reason i got fired was
it was it was lack of
performance in a sales job yeah and uh i
said you know
in this environment it just wasn't it
wasn't the right fit for me so i said
man
i i need to start my own business so i
did it and it's been
it's been incredible good good for you
man all right so you've got a carpet
cleaning business
management has always been restructuring
in your life that's my good will hunting
reference
and but now you got your own place and
you're crushing it so what's up
yep so i've got to nest you this is this
is the this is kind of the emotional
uh concern i have because i listen to a
lot of business books and
tactical stuff like that of do this do
that use budget here's this
anyway i've got a nephew 21 years old
he's coming out of prison of the last
three years
i would love to help him out in some way
to bring him on and and and
work in the business with me and kind of
be a a mentor if i
if you will um his sister or my my
sister his mom and i are
super close like we're and so she's just
concerned for him and
and i and i want to know like what's the
best way i can help him
but also not jeopardize the integrity of
what i've built
what we've what we've built as a team
and a culture here with with my business
because coming from a background of of
theft and burglary
yep i'm hoping that he's had a a come to
jesus moment
but we're in people's homes we're in
people's businesses
they trust us with door codes and keys
and and
all kinds of stuff that we've built a
reputation for how do i help him
but not jeopardize what we've what we've
built sounds like
you don't want to hire him but you think
it would help him
that's exactly okay so
hiring him would cause you to treat him
with a little more scrutiny with a
little closer eye
with probably a little less of a leash
than you do your other employees or than
with yourself
which then would cause that relationship
to strain further and a partridge in a
pear tree is that fair
ah yeah so here there's there's really
two ways you can do it number one
you when he gets out you could say you
could sit him down and say i'm gonna
take the risk of a lifetime because i'm
gonna gamble my entire thing on you
because yeah and you tell him what you
just told me a hundred percent of my job
is based on trust
sure there's a million different carpet
cleaners and i don't i don't know if you
guys are just
if there's like a michael jordan of
carpet cleaning you may be it right
my guess is like at the end of the day
the tools or the tools and the chemicals
or the chemicals
it comes down to do i show up on time do
i
leave this place do i do good work
obviously but am i a pleasure to do
business with
am i fair and honest right all those
things you've built up over the last
three years right
absolutely 100 so sitting down and
saying
you can take all of this from me with
one stupid move
and i'm gonna go all in on you and trust
you
and he can say i'm gonna rise to the
challenge i've learned my lesson this
will never happen i'm a changed person
so colin i'll tell you this i was a
little
punk thief when i was a kid okay
a punk thief okay
and i had some things happen in my life
i never went to jail
um i never stole on a big scale or
anything like that right
i was always taking kids baseball card i
was just a punk man
and dude there are a few things
that get me more fired up on earth than
a thief now
than someone who steals oh absolutely
okay so i'm telling you that to tell you
i have had a change of heart a massive
one
and now um i do whatever i can to make
sure that
that level of integrity is whole in my
life
right comically so to the point that my
friends and family are like dude it's
just 14 cents you don't have to take it
back to the store
we're all getting back in the car we're
going back to the store that right so i
want to tell you
change does happen right people do grow
i wouldn't do this job if it wasn't for
that
the other side of that is is day two out
of jail the day to start that i don't
know
you know him right the other thing you
can do
besides sitting him down and being that
honest with him and then going all in on
him
which i don't know is the wrong move i
get from you that you don't think that's
the right one but you can do that
or you can sit him down and tell him
you've got six months you've got one
calendar year i want you to go work your
butt off i want you to show
us right not punitively i want you to
show
us who you've become yeah and then i'll
be ready when you're ready
or you can take him to lunch or to
breakfast once a week
and mentor him that way hey how are
things going how are you
are you plug does that make sense um you
can pour into him in other ways
instead of just you've been fired a lot
right
you've had you've had ups and downs in
your life you can talk to him about
getting knocked down and getting back up
right you've got a lot to offer besides
just a job
here's my interesting question what's
your sisters
want you to do what's she saying
you know she was she was very
apprehensive she said hey
she goes she started the conversation
you can say no to this
but essentially can you is there any way
you can help
ah there you go and i said and i said
and
and she's not she's not looking for a
handout she she want like she actually
called the police and put him in jail
before wow okay
so so we're coming from we're coming
from a place where
we're not we're not afraid to beat him
up yeah but in in
in a good way like look if you you mess
up like
don't don't put me don't put our our
lives in jeopardy by your silly
decisions you're not you're not afraid
to hold him accountable which is awesome
he's he's blessed to have you guys
that's cool
um so correct what do you think the
right move is
you know the suggestion you made was one
of the exact suggestions i
i told my sister i said look i said i
love him
like i i enjoy spending time with him as
as a young man but again that was three
years ago sure and so
um he literally is not even out of out
of prison yet
but it's supposed to be the next in the
next week or so but anyway with that
being said
um i told her i said look i said he's
got to show
before unless he's directly next
to me like in my eyesight i will
never send him on a job by himself for
at least
a calendar year okay and if he messes up
one time like i've got i've
i've got to let him go yeah and so or
or like you were saying like he's got to
prove himself somewhere else where
he's not he's somewhere else for a full
calendar year before i even bring him on
and take him into people's homes how old
is he
he's 21 21. so he's
he's a in the eyes of the law he's a
grown man he's still a kid
right and if he's been in jail for three
of the last years he's he's still a
child
right he had to grow up and learn hard
stuff right i would recommend having
this conversation with his mom in the
room
and you know what would be really great
for everybody is for you to call out
how uncomfortable this is for everybody
to let him know hey your decisions have
potentially put a wedge between me and
one of the women i love the most in the
world which is my sister
because i want to help you and she's
desperate for you to get some help
but now because of your decisions we
love you
but now i'm in a weird spot because my
business is all based on trust
and so i'm going to lay out the
boundaries here one calendar year or
six calendar months or whatever it is
sure you meet with me
every other week for a year you make a
budget with me let me know that you are
making good solid decisions you don't
miss
work at your new job dude you're going
to come on and me and you are going to
take over the world
with our carpet cleaning business right
but i'm going to invest in you but i'm
not just going gonna
hand it out to you as you walk out
because this is about trust and you get
that's what you gotta earn back right
and man i think by just laying it all
out there that keeps you and your sister
from getting crossed with one another
because he's gonna get out it's gonna be
hard for him to find a job that's the
reality
and then she's going to start getting
more frustrated with you and more
frustrated with you right
and this is just a way to clear that
deck right away
everybody's in the room everybody knows
my plan is i'm going to stick to this
plan
and then he's cool you're cool and he
may say dude i want to work carpet clean
and you say
high five brother we're still gonna i'm
still gonna have breakfast with you
whatever right
um yeah but you're able to hold your
head up high put some boundaries in
there and let him know he's loved and
he's connected and and
purchasing a pear tree and my hope is
two years from now
you guys have the most dominator
carpet cleaning business on planet earth
just you two rocking and rolling right
that would be ideal
i love your heart and i love not only
your heart
but your rational thinking how do i best
love him not how do i best just make
everybody feel good really quick and
then potentially lose my business lose
my sister lose my
nephew in the process right good for you
good for you
let me know how this goes as you all
have that conversation as you move on
down the road
i'm rooting for you i'm rooting for him
that's awesome all right let's go to
rosie in
henderson nevada rosie what's going on
hey how are you so good how are you
um peachy that is the
that is the dr john deloney show first
peachy that's incredible oh yeah works
we don't have a lot of
fruit references on this show we've got
to get more of those james has been
telling me in my notes we've got to get
more fruit references
and here comes a rosie dropping one on
us so thank you so much so what's going
on how can i help
so pretty much i i just need to know how
i can
i got a dui and okay i'm a mom
so it's really weighing on me it's just
really
i just can't seem to like i feel like
i'm stained or something pretty much
like okay so how old how old are your
kids
oh they're nine months and two years
nine months in two years okay
and then tell me about this dui what was
going on so
i was at a bridal shower my friend's
vital shower
apparently had too much wine
and i mean i felt like i was fine i was
like drinking water and trying to be
responsible but
hey hold on real quick let's back up so
i want to
we're going to as part of this we're
going to start changing the narrative
and it's because it's going to change
the narrative in your soul okay
so instead of saying apparently and
evidently say
i went to a bridal shower and i drank
too much
that cool i did yep and i thought i felt
fine but i wasn't
is that cool i want you to take
ownership language okay
yeah all right so tell me again you had
a bridal shuttle
shower and then what so i drank too much
at the bridal shower
i thought i could drive home
i ended up falling asleep at a red light
and uh either someone
called it into the cops so they pretty
much one cop parked in front of me one
cop
parked behind me to wake me up that way
i didn't like driving to the
intersection
and i mean from
there i had my i got taken to jail and
had
got arrested you so you
you fell you i'm smiling here not at you
but
with you you you didn't doze off you
like crashed
yeah yeah so is were you did you fall
asleep because
you're you had seven drinks or did you
fall asleep because you had just enough
and you're a mom of two little bitty
kids um i definitely
do not get a lot of sleep with the baby
right so
and it wasn't like super late at night
or anything i guess that was like hey
here's a good chance to catch up on some
sleep
but obviously drinking we're gonna catch
up right here at
uh fourth and mockingbird lane right
sounds good wow so you went to sleep to
sleep
um how far over the limit were you
um i didn't they took my blood so it
wasn't
they didn't like breathalyze me or
anything so
i'm not sure but i had to be held for at
least 12 hours
okay and you know go home
are you married yeah how was that phone
call
um well the cops called him not me i
didn't really get to talk to him until i
got out but
so paint paint the listeners a picture
of that
drive home your husband comes to get you
out of jail and you come out oh no
i ended up getting a a lyft home
but oh he made you get a ride home well
he was home with the kids it was like
5 00 a.m so oh boy
i didn't want yeah i just luckily my
phone was still
alive i kind of wanted to take the drive
of shame by myself anyway
all right that's fair
man that would have made a christmas
story 20 years from now like hey y'all
remember the time we wouldn't pick your
mom up from jail
um so you get a lift home and you come
in
yeah he's just home well home on the
couch with the baby
but it was just kind of big we were just
trying to be quiet it wasn't much of a
conversation because of the kids
yeah but i mean later on
obviously he was upset but he he was
just also like
not understanding but calm cool and
collected
sure so here's the thing you don't have
a stain on you
okay answer answer these questions these
aren't rhetorical did you do something
dumb
yeah yeah did you put a whole bunch of
people at risk
yep you did okay was it stupid
absolutely yeah will it ever happen
again
no okay so you got
super super super lucky you didn't hurt
anybody
you got super super lucky that your two
little babies
still have a mom and
you got super super lucky that somebody
called it in and that someone didn't
smash you from behind because you were
asleep at us at a stoplight right
so cosmically you got real lucky
and you got a husband that loves you and
was able to be there for your kids and
roll his eyes and say oh my gosh how
expensive is this going to be
um well just the lawyers right now it's
just the base pay of like
2 000. yeah it'll probably be about 10
grand by the time you get done with it
that was the last number i heard
so it's going to be real real expensive
if you're like me
you don't have 10 grand laying around so
this is going to hurt right
so if you choose to carry this around
like i'm a loser and i'm an idiot and
i've got a stain on me
then this is going to affect your kids
this is going to affect your husband
this is going to affect your friendships
and relationships
if you can stand up tall
hold your head up not use words not use
adverbs not use l-y words apparently
evidently
if you say yep i screwed up big time and
i got busted
and then i went to jail and then i paid
my ten thousand dollars in lawyers fees
and court costs etc
and i will never ever do that again
and it is what it is and at some point
your 10 year old's gonna come bouncing
into the room mom did you ever go to
jail and you'll have to go
have a seat you know what i mean that
will be part of it
but you're not gonna shy away from it
you're not gonna lie you're not gonna be
weird about it you're gonna say yeah
your mom made a bad
dumb decision and this is why as you
noticed this is why like i do these
things right
this is why i never drink alcohol at a
friend's house this is why i don't drive
anywhere i always get an
uber whatever whatever whatever
behavioral decision you're going to
change
and then you're going to hold your head
high and make sure this never happens
again
right yeah yeah i just yeah
anything beyond that rosie is a choice
is you choosing to hang on to this
longer than necessary
beating yourself up further doesn't help
anything
it doesn't make it not happen it doesn't
make it
um it doesn't make other people feel bad
for you
it just makes everything mush right
and it's not forgetting it it's not
undermining it it's not saying that
wasn't a big deal was a huge deal you
got real lucky
and now we're going to move on so why
why is that hard why don't why don't you
want to choose to do that
i just see i just get these like when
i'm home and i just see the kids playing
together or something new the baby did i
just still
i get these flashbacks of you know the
jail and yep
just these guilty pains of like i
couldn't be here right now whether
breathing or just in a jail cell for
like multiple other reasons and so
it's just continuous like oh what a
happy moment and then
you know the the guilt the flashback
there you go okay so you ready you've
probably heard me do this on this show
but we're gonna do it again anyway i'm
gonna do it a thousand more times before
i finally get canceled
you ready yeah close your eyes real
quick
okay are they closed i want you to
picture in your head
a giant um i don't know
a a green donkey
okay sitting in your front yard sitting
down not standing sitting in a weird
stance
got it okay that donkey is sitting there
and i want you to have
a yellow hat on his head cool
you got it in your head yep all right
open your eyes
you just proved to the everyone
listening to this show you can control
your thoughts
so when you're sitting down playing with
your little baby
right you're two-month-old you're
nine-month or two-year-old and you're
nine month old
and that thought of that freezing cold
concrete little chair bed thing right
i want you to go nope and then choose
in that moment to focus on your
two-year-old
come up with some sort of trigger which
is every time you think of jail
you reach out and grab her hand you
reach out and grab his
his little head in your hand and you
tickle it
come up with some sort and what you're
doing is you are choosing
in short order i'm not going to dwell on
these things
because we are done with them right
yeah anything other than that is a
choice
and what will happen over time really in
short order
is they will stop flashing into your
mind you'll stop walking around like a
failed mother
okay you will hopefully never forget
that you endangered a whole bunch of
people including yourself
that you almost you did something dumb
enough that could have left your husband
on his own with two little kids okay why
don't you ever forget
that but the guilt and the hood and the
participation and i'm no good i'm gonna
lose
we're done with that okay because it
will only drag down everyone around you
it'll only drag you down okay you
learned
you're gonna live and move on okay and
then you're gonna work to control your
thoughts as they pop into your head
okay thank you so much for that call i
know that's hard rosie man i'm still
dealing with crap
i said when i was 14 right i see my kid
i'm like man
you're kind of dad's the dad that says
it and i go nope not doing that man
because i was 14 i was a child and yep i
shouldn't have said that but i did and
now i'm moving on because i don't say
that anymore right whatever the behavior
happens to be okay
all right so um we're gonna kind of slip
off into a geek segment here
what do we call the geek minute is that
what we call it it's a teaching segment
geek minute um i get a bunch of emails
about
sleep right i get a bunch of emails
about sleep
here's an example kelly pulled for me
from mason
i've noticed when it comes to anxiety
you talk very highly of the importance
of sleep can you talk about how much
sleep we should be getting
what not to do before bed when's too
late or too early to work out etc i've
been dealing with lots of anxiety and
keeping my sleep on track is
nearly impossible to me all right so
i am a huge fan of sleep researcher
out of berkeley california of university
of berkeley
dr matthew walker he's got a remarkable
book called why we sleep
he was on a podcast with dr peter a t
it's called the drive podcast after this
one go to dr
peter tia's drive podcast it's a
three-part series on sleep
and they go off the deep end six
hours on sleep and you're talking about
the neurochemistry the biochemist all of
it
right if you want a deep deep deep dive
it's the best interview it's the best
discussion on sleep i've ever i've ever
heard
um it's for nerds it really is but it's
also high level too
but it'll be in the show notes yeah
here's the thing
i'm going to walk through several things
about sleep that are revolutionary that
are mind-blowing
and that are really important dr walker
says that
sleep is the greatest legal performance
enhancing drug that most
people are probably neglecting now as i
get into these things i always want you
to remember
follow the money right so you're going
to ask yourself why did i not know that
sleep
prevents all of these things we're going
to run through here
because it's free and it's something
every one of us can do
every night of our lives for free and it
can solve
a lot of challenges in our life
but nobody can charge you for sleep so
you don't hear about it very often
so for years insomnia has been labeled a
symptom of depression or anxiety right
and that means that if you had anxiety
or depression one thing they would ask
you is
are you struggling with sleep and you'd
say yeah and they go yeah you got
anxiety
turns out it's the other way around a
lack of
sleep causes many of these mental health
conditions
root cause causal not is is related to
helps cause some of these things like
depression anxiety and paranoia
right walker says without sleep our
brain
reverts to a primitive pattern of
uncontrolled reactivity
we produce unmetered inappropriate
emotional emotional reactions
and are unable to place events into a
broader context
or a considered context what does that
mean
how many of you have not slept for 24
hours you pull an all-nighter
and then you just start laughing and you
can't help it you just start laughing
laughing laughing or
you're on in your car on your way to
that exam and a song comes on the radio
and you start crying
right or it's it's week two after um
15 hour work day 15 hour work day you're
just crushing a project
and you're watching the show and you
start bawling right or
your husband walks in and says hey i'm
going to um i'm not going to do the
dishes tonight let's go out to eat and
you just slash
i can't believe it right you just
launched into him right
our amygdala gets heightened heightened
heightened height and heightened with
less sleep less sleepless sleep
one study found that people derived of
sleep for four hours
per night for two weeks suffered a
50 reduced ability to dispose of glucose
into muscle tissue
what does that mean that means that a
lack of sleep
can increase your risk of diabetes and
insulin resistance and weight gain a
lack of sleep
can increase your risk of alzheimer's
disease reduce the activity of your
immune system it's easier to get
sick impairs learning and memory i was
the king of all-nighters turns out i was
an idiot
right increases your risk for
cardiovascular disease increases your
risk for cancer
contributes to root cause depression and
anxiety
now most important type of sleep right
the one that calms and resets the
anxious brain
is non-rapid eye movement in rem sleep
it's a slow wave streak right
you can reduce anxiety in a single night
with deep deep sleep people with anxiety
disorders routinely report having
disturbed sleep but rarely asleep
improvement considered as a clinical
recommendation for lung anxiety
not only are is there a causal
connection
but it's the type of sleep right so
here's the thing
over the last hundred years last 200
years
what happens we get oil lamps
so usually we just go to bed when the
sun went down we get oil lamps
we get light bulbs we get tv
we get radio we get tv now we all have
devices
there is street lights everywhere
there's house lights everywhere
so overnight bam
15 20 25 30 of the natural sleep cycle
has just been lopped off
right and these things are
critical to brain function i love this
dr walker says that the brain acts like
a plumbing system
that discards toxins from the body but
it does this
during sleep okay here's another thing
ambient lunesta these are not
um like those over-the-counter sleep
meds
they're called hypnotics they per
they produce um for lack of better terms
they produce unconsciousness
they don't produce sleep so i heard it
put this way
these are pharmaceutical baseball bats
to the head
i can make you unconscious for eight
hours that is different
than sleeping for eight hours i know
this because i took those medicines for
years i used to train in mixed martial
arts our
practices would go from eight to ten
eight to ten thirty at night
i'd get home all amped up and i couldn't
sleep
well i had one of those pills and i'd go
right out into a black hole
turns out over years my brain wasn't
getting the sleep it needed
surprise surprise daloni ends up
crawling around his backyard with
mind crippling anxiety right with
numbing depression i wasn't sleeping
wasn't sleeping wasn't sleeping so
here's a couple of things you can do two
as walker says
bridge the best bridge between despair
and hope is a good night of sleep so
here you go
number one you can make fun of this all
you want this is not what you were told
as a kid i don't care
try it for two months 60 days get like a
calendar and mark them off
try it just try it number one go to bed
and wake up at the same time every night
even after a bad night's sleep
and even on saturday and sunday some of
us get up at five o'clock five o'clock
five o'clock five o'clock on sunday we
sleep until eight
you screw it all up some of us go to bed
at eight at nine o'clock nine o'clock
nine o'clock midnight
go to bed the best you can at the same
time every day and get up at the same
time even on the weekend
after 30 days you're going to be stunned
because your body will begin to reset
itself
keep your bedroom super cool about 65
degrees is optimal right
if your feet get cold you can wear socks
i use a chili cube
cube chili cube we'll put in the show
notes there it's a little device it
circulates water through
a sheet that goes under my sheet because
my wife i don't know is
is part polar bear i think and she likes
or no she's part regular bear she likes
everything warm
and i like it freezing cold um but it
will drop the temperature down
into the low 60s or even high 50s
and in the summertime i run that thing
all summer and it is awesome okay
it's expensive it's been worth it for me
especially if you run hot natured
an hour before bedtime turn the lights
off dim the electronics i actually have
special glasses that block the lights
blackout curtains can be helpful
right i live out in the country now the
only thing that keeps me awake now out
there is the stupid moon
and i give it a few days because that
sounds pretty natural
if you can't sleep i give it 10 or 15
minutes and then i get up
and i go read i get up reset what you
don't want to do is to remind your body
to start developing a pattern where
going to bed
is something that makes me stressed and
crazy don't work in bed bed is for sex
and bed is for sleep and that is it
right watch tv in another room um
uh do work don't just sit in your bed
with your laptop working right up until
you close the laptop and try to go to
sleep your brains gotta cycle down okay
here's another big one don't drink
caffeine after lunch i don't drink
caffeine after 10 a.m
unless i got something that i have to do
for work late into the evening
i just don't the half-life on coffee is
way way longer than we thought
here's another one alcohol is a sedative
but it is not
sleep you feel like you're getting
sleepy and you
actually go to sleep but alcohol blocks
rem dream sleep which is the critical
important part of deep sleep
right alcohol will ruin your sleep
so if i have drinks out with friends i
consciously know
i'm choosing socializing over good sleep
and this is going to cost me for the
next few days
and over the last few years as i have
prioritized sleep over
and above all other things all of the
health related things
i've begun to drink way way way way less
now i just have water out with buddies
right i'll have a decaffeinated tea or
decaf coffee
i hope i'm still fun i think i still am
but i drink way way less right
i do take magnesium gaba hemp oil
occasional metal melatonin these are
sleep encouragers
these are not hypnotics they're not
sedatives
right um and i work with a doctor on
those that i trust here's the thing
um not working out after five or six
don't work out
without two or three hours before you go
to bed if kelly just perked up she's
like that's one time i can go to the gym
if you do it's gonna push you up okay so
i would say
at least two to three hours before you
try to go to bed don't be exercising
okay
um that also doesn't mean don't work out
until 9 30 or 10 at night and then go to
bed at 1 am and get up at 5. don't do
that either right
you got to get your time to sleep how
long is good time of sleep
seven to nine hours for most people if
you think
oh no i just need four hours almost
almost to a person you're wrong there's
a very few people who can get by on that
it's probably not
you maybe jocko not you
maybe i don't know some not you
right not you most
people walk through life chronically
chronically under sleeping
and if you don't think this is a big
deal if you remember a few years ago the
big stink with netflix when they said we
have two competitors youtube and sleep
and we think our best route is to go
after sleep there's a lot of excitement
a lot of
great tv shows a lot of garbage tv shows
a lot of clicky flashy brighty things
that keep you from going to bed
what i want you to do for 60 days is
prioritize going to sleep
and if you have a night this is a big
one if you have a night where you don't
sleep i get those occasionally
they don't bother me anymore they used
to stress
me out so bad they'd make me nuts oh my
gosh i gotta sleep i gotta sleep i gotta
sleep i'm gonna be a wreck
you know what now i just get up and read
i get up and i read
and then the next day it makes it back
up and i go to sleep i'm going to be all
right
and i don't freak out i don't lose it's
going to be okay
and so in honor of sleep night right
um in honor of sleep sleep night here
the sleep show here i pulled this song
from 1992 it's one of the greatest songs
ever written especially if you like good
musicians
all of these guys in this band are
better than you and better than anybody
you know of
and they they play metal and opera
and keyboardy things and 80s what i
don't know they're just awesome
right i remember seeing them in concert
opening up for joe satriani and i just
didn't speak for a while they're the
most extraordinary live band i've ever
seen
but in 1992 they caught my attention on
their images and words record
dream theater james do you like dream
theater
no i get i get progy about other bands
but i'm not into the dream theater yeah
i see
and you know what else he also plays
fender guitars which is a whole other
conversation we should probably have
someday it's ridiculous
gibson brother do you want this episode
to air or not here we go all right so
dream theaters 1992
classic song pull me under i don't know
that's a veiled reference to sleep i
guess
it doesn't really work but i'm gonna go
with it and here here they go
they sing lost by the way prog bands
have all of these like
theatery artsy words even
i'm like okay here's the one here's the
words
lost in the sky clouds roll by and i
roll with them
arrows fly and the seas increase and
then fall again
this world is spinning around me this
world is spinning without me in
every day since future to pass every
breath
leaves me one less to my last
[Laughter]
kelly's eyes just rolled through the
back of her head watch the sparrow
falling
gives new meaning to it all does it if
not today
nor yet tomorrow than some other day
i'll take seven lives for one
and then my only father's son as sure as
i did ever love him
i am not afraid let's hold that
pull me under pull me under i'm not
afraid
everybody go to sleep this has been the
dr john dolone show
[Music]
you